well the group had promised an inclusive
government representing all afghans but
there are no women shia or previous
administration officials who were chosen
to take part
let's go through the list acting prime
minister muhammad hassan akund is a
taliban founding member he served as
foreign minister and deputy prime
minister during the group's last stint
in power from 1996 to 2001.
the taliban co-founder popularly known
as mullah barada has been named as the
deputy prime minister
he headed the group's political office
in doha and has been the taliban's most
visible face in recent years
the acting defense minister is muhammad
yaqub he is the eldest son of the
taliban founder mula omar he's a
military commander and has rarely been
seen in the public eye
sarah juden haqqani will become interior
minister he is head of the haqqani
network which has been blamed for some
of afghanistan's most violent attacks in
recent years
finally the role of foreign minister
will be filled by amir khan mutaki who
took part in negotiations with the
united states
let's go to charles stratford who's live
for us in kabul charleston the taliban
has announced this all-male interim
government made up by old guard taliban
figures how is this likely to go down
with ordinary afghans
well i mean certainly ordinary afghans
were told a very different story uh by
the taliban i think it's fair to say
that uh
afghans were looking forward to
possibly a far more inclusive government
than this as you say a government that
would have at least had appointments
women appointed um a more
ethnically diverse
cabinet
and wider appointments that simply
hasn't happened yet
a taliban spokesperson last night said
that obviously this is not a permanent
government this is an interim interim
administration and implied that later on
when more ministries are announced then
in his words things like women's rights
would be better accounted for but there
were no great details given there and as
you say all these main members are
taliban figures and figures that were
had some sort of role in the previous
taliban government or have been right at
the forefront of the fighting against
u.s led nato forces and the previous
government here
and i'm sure that afghans are very
concerned about what
that means for them in the eyes of the
western world when you have figures like
sir jadin
haqaani the leader of the haqqani
network a group that you know the west
blames for some of the most terrible
attacks in recent years
who is on a wanted list an organization
that haka is listed as a terror
organization when he is made the interim
interior minister you can imagine what a
lot of people here think
when there are complaints by the west
that this has happened and the west is
saying well
unless this is a more inclusive
government unless the taliban behaves
and acts on commitments with respect to
human rights you're not going to get any
money which of course has an immediate
effect on the millions of afghans here
living in poverty that according to the
u.n and almost half the population is in
need of humanitarian aid
and of course that is dependent on money
being unfrozen the world bank has frozen
tens of millions of dollars we know that
the u.s government has
around 9.5 billion
dollars frozen in u.s accounts as well
the taliban last night according to
their spokesperson still says that you
know this will be
an inclusive uh administration that will
uh that will take on board those ideas
that they need to be given a chance they
will prove themselves
but analysts will tell you that
many analysts are not surprised that
this has happened and it's another
example they say
of um despite pressures from the west
despite pressures
from um you know many elements within
this country um the taliban will do as
they please
so yeah all eyes on
more western reaction which we expect to
be receiving today
and also obviously more eyes on exactly
what kind of reaction there will be
inside afghan afghanistan by ordinary
afghans
many thanks for that charles stratford
beverage in kabul